if you had to battle horrifying flesh
eating monsters what would you do the
country is about to be overrun with
creatures from hell and the only way to
stop them will be by disrespecting
innocent dead bodies punching Crazy
Horse Gods right in the face and acting
like our favorite Little Ghost Hunter
yayoi from the anime dark gathering in
order to save the world I'm going to
break down the mistakes made what you
should do and how to beat the yah held
demons in blood raid curse of the Y this
man is going to watch his entire country
get killed by flesh eating monsters that
wear the skin of their victims Hiag here
is an elite ninja that is about to find
out the worst news of all his best
friend Maro has suspiciously run away
and his leader has been brutally
murdered by Yoma mythical blood sucking
creatures that feed on humans and can
wear their skins to hide in plain sight
his ninja Clan thinks Maro is somehow
responsible for their Leader's death and
tell hikkake to go find him and kill him
before word gets out that their leader
has died because all hell will break
loose if that happen not realizing that
hell is already at their doorstep with
no choice Hiag sets off on an Epic
Journey that will force him to go up
against y spirits and mythical Gods but
his clan warns him of what Horrors he's
about to face Japan is stting to get
more attacks by the Y the whole country
is on red alert but they foolishly think
the problem will soon be cleared up
setting off to kill his former best
friend Hiag soon senses trouble suddenly
a shuriken flies past his face he gets
attacked by ninjas like him fighting for
his life using his Elite skills he
appears from the sky slicing this enemy
in half throwing some grenades setting
off a massive explosion and he runs away
from more incoming trouble disappear ing
into this field and he figures out his
next move okay as we're both honorable
ninjas here I would work on taking this
guy out in the most dishonorable way
possible with a game of rock tag let me
explain we're fighting against EGA
ninjas one of the most famous Clans in
Japan known for being skilled in things
basically like hit-and run tactics
infiltration disguise gorilla Warfare
and better fighting in forests and
mountains this strength we can use
against them since we just entered a
flat field and their weakness is
fighting head on and as I said we're
both honorable ninjas so the best way to
defeat him would be by being
dishonorable as hell while running I
would collect any natural items Rock
from nature and hiding before luring the
ninja up close to use his sword from
here I would use one of the rocks or
hard items that I find earlier and hide
it in my non-dominant hand while
concealing it by pretending to hold my
sheath assuming a battle ready position
the enemy approaching seeing us in this
position would expect us to perform a
draw cut technique based on our stance
as he charges at us however this is when
I would throw the Rock from our
non-dominant hand Adam last minute while
using our dominant hand holding the to
perform the draw cut maneuver he was
expecting blinds signing him with the
rock first would throw him off our sword
strike would either kill him or injure
him enough in order for us to easily
take him out right after and there you
go beating a ninja in the most
dishonorable way possible he surprised
attacks his final opponent pile driving
him locking his arm and brutally
breaking his neck out of breath he
senses something sinister approaching
this old man but something about him is
off he tells hiang that he is a priest
and has come to give him his last rights
because he won't be alive for much
longer taking him to his Temple the old
man starts acting shady saying this area
is where people come to transition in
life Hiag doesn't understand what he
means but he will soon find out how evil
this man really is finding out tomorrow
isn't here he's about to leave but the
old man tells him he should rest at the
nearby Village because he will die if he
stays out tonight okay that's weird the
priest claims he somehow knows about the
country's Yoma problem and reveals Japan
will not win this war and is on the
verge of getting overrun because soon
there will be more Yoma than human they
can do nothing but wait to die thinking
he's crazy he quickly leaves but since
is two Ninjas nearby and one unknown
monster headed in different directions
making him realize that something fishy
going on in this Village but that's when
he hears somebody singing nearby and
runs into this girl from the village not
saying anything she takes him to her
home and he spots all the locals
partying without a care in the world and
she invites him to join Hiag hesitates
but she tells him night is soon coming
and he must stay with a little Choice he
lets loose and is about to join the
party just as he spots his former best
friend and Target in the middle of
everything he tries to follow him but
gets stopped by this villager to keep on
drinking making Mak him wonder if he's
imagining things not realizing that this
is actually a really terrifying sign
later that night staying with the
village girl he tells her why he's here
and finds out her name is ya but she
tells them she's never seen someone
named Maro here since most people from
this Village are Travelers that come and
go and she can tell that he's tense she
tells him to relax while he's here
another woman named Ito stops by to give
him some new clothes for free but that's
when Hiag notices something strange cuz
this Village seems too good to be true
but somehow he goes to sleep what the
heck is wrong with him and he's unaware
that he's being watched press for time
the next day he starts investigating
this area because he's noticed three
strange things since he's arrived here
he hasn't heard or seen any animals up
until now strange there aren't any rice
fields nearby to feed anyone and they
were just parting it up like nobody's
business and the village has been acting
way too nice to him okay if I was them I
would focus Less on the drinking and
more on the chopping off of everyone's
Willies right now it makes no sense why
hik is wasting time drinking the night
away run the clock if the Yoma outbreak
gets worse in Japan it will be every man
for himself and the one thing more
dangerous than monsters in Apocalypse is
man himself if I was him I would start
thinking like a detective over a ninja
and would start by figuring out who saw
Maro at any point even if it was just
one time in order to create a timeline
of when he came and left or didn't cuz
right now we have no idea when our
Target got here and the longer we wait
the more the locals will forget what our
friend looks like since long-term memory
can also affect someone's ability to
remember face details depending on
factors like how emotionally impacted
they were by that person if Maro didn't
stay long and didn't interact much with
anyone here there's a higher chance that
the locals memory of him won't last long
at all however I would go back to the
priest and torture the [__] out of him
and give more information before killing
him at this point the world is at stake
and one or two innocent casualties in
the grand scheme really won't matter
depending on the information we get from
the priest I would then go back and get
info out of the village through a simple
peaceful two-step system step one start
off by being friendly and vulnerable to
the villagers sharing them my deepest
desires and building a bond with them
before pressing them about our Target
and what they know to if this doesn't
work I would begin chopping off
everyone's Willies one by one and begin
slicing some people's faces and force
them to Spill the Beans which should
happen pretty quickly since they have no
reason to hold any loyalty to him cuz at
this point there is no reason to beat
around the bush Hiag is taking this way
too slow for a man on a mission Hiag
realizes the same people watching him
from yesterday are still watching him
now and he thinks he knows them that
night in his room he actually gets
secretly called to go outside finally
meeting a stalkers ninjas from his clan
his men questioned why he stilled The
Village because Maro was only spotted
passing through here once and staying
here longer is pointless Hiag tells them
they're wrong because he saw him
yesterday and begs them to let him stay
and look a little longer because they
used to be Bros feeling sorry for him
these two agree to give him two more
days continuing his search the next
night he hears a scream in her sleep
rushing to take care of her but more
screams start coming from outside of the
village going to investigate that's when
he runs into the most horrifying crime
scene he's ever seen Hing up the area
full of bloody guts strange cobwebs and
this disfigured body no man could have
done this he realizes that these wounds
weren't made by normal weapons but
something far more monstrous inspecting
the victims he recognizes this one from
the village and suddenly he reacts and
throws his shuriken into the bush
spotting something evil Escape it must
be a y all right so we got a lot going
on right now but really the most
important thing to do is to disrespect
the crap out of this corpse all for the
sake of our mission of course we finally
spotted a Yoma In the Flesh we should
have been more alert from the moment we
saw the bite marks on this Victim
Because bite marks here are bigger than
the biggest predator in Japan we know
the country is being Infested by y so
obviously I would have come more
prepared than hikkake did showing up
with at least my sword not just some
tiny small edged weapons ninjas in
general like to wear lightweight
flexible clothing with little armor to
Aid in speed and movement which is fine
normally seriously all he has to do is
to slap on a bigger sword and he would
have been way better off and this is
only part of the problem because the
village we've been investigating has
been acting like nothing is wrong
everything's fine it's great come party
this is why I would disrespect this
victim's Body by moving the corpse
before it gets even colder back to the
Village immediately and finally offer
proof to the villagers that something is
actually going on because up until this
point we haven't had any evidence of
what is going on and this is caused by
the villagers to have plausible
deniability bringing the corpse back
like this would also help us find out
two things depending on how the village
reacts I would know if they're
certifiably crazy or if they were lying
and if they are crazy I could then
immediately stop treating them like
human beings and more like nothing more
than sources of information torturing
and killing them in order to finally see
if they're holding out any more
information about our mission because at
this point Hiag has been acting way too
soft and slowly dragging out this part
the anime any longer than he needed to
and it's starting to piss me off another
creature surprises aack KAG barely
avoiding death he quickly beats it up
and chases it away to spotting marrow
again but this time it's clear as day
not realizing what's going on this one
victim barely clinging to life reveals a
new piece of information about his best
friend delivering a cryptic message he
says Maro was born from the ground and
is secretly Pure Evil and soon the
monsters will revive him Hiag here has
no idea what he's talking about and he
thinks he must be suffering from blood
loss but that's when he tells him that
his clan has known about the is all
along and Maro is evil there is no way
the stranger could know this information
and hiaki tries to ask more questions
but as we all know in anime the dude
suddenly dies he rushes to go tell a
about her villager friend that just died
but she tells him this Village is known
for travelers coming and going and he's
probably off traveling again laughing
and off hake thinks everyone here is
gone insane a heads inside but secret
hears an evil voice putting her in a
trance and gives her one order to carry
out later that night Hiag tries to sleep
but he hears the faint sound of someone
singing deep in the forest warrant never
to go there at night and with a not here
he realizes that person singing must be
her he rushes to check on her and that's
when he spots horrifying cobwebs
everywhere blocking his vision and he
sees ya in the distance near this
monster raing his weapons he rips
through the webs finally seeing what he
couldn't before A's guts getting fed on
by this terrifying y bursting in Rage
Hiag launches his shuriken taking out
his sword he attacks cutting off the Y's
leg but gets violently knocked back let
the Y get away he's useless chasing
after it he comes across the same priest
from earlier pissed off he demands to
know what's going on but the priest
tells him he's already told him what
this Village was making him finally
piece together the clues this village
houses the bottom Losers of society and
uses them for sacrifice shocking Hiag he
doesn't believe him the priest tells him
their King kigo Niko was born as a human
but must be reborn again to overcome
humanity and rule the world and tells
them that hikkake knows who this king is
not listening anymore he charges at the
priest but ce's bone starts breaking and
transforms into a full-on y and the two
get ready for a death match
okay I would use some similar tactics to
take out this y like yayoi did in the
sick anime dark Gathering baby here's
how we do it Hiag is acting way too
emotional right now by running straight
into the monster's home turf don't do
that this monster is familiar with this
area and would be able to surprise an
overwhelm him due to his sheer size and
tentacles if I was him I would have
leveraged armor ability right now as
yayoi did in the anime dark Gathering
against the dark tunnel F ghost Yeah by
luring the Y outside into a more open
area that had less trees reducing it
ability to attack us from different
angles by luring it back to the Village
we could use the environment against it
like using the rope from the well
located there which we passed by earlier
and we could have used it to try and tie
it around the Y's human face and this
would have severely restricted its
movement and would have allowed us to
approach it from behind and kill it
swiftly and with way less risk fighting
in literally any other area away from
the Y's Lair would have been better than
what Hiag did just right now acting on a
pure emotion that's not what you do
that's not what a professional does the
horrifying Yoma easily overpowers him
and throws him back shooting its webs at
hikage and it strikes aose range but
this ninja gets in a lucky shock shot
stabbing the y in the face bleeding out
Hiag prepares to kill it but it tells
him that if he dies the whole village
will die as well warning him there's no
saving people who clearly don't want to
be saved the Y reveals the villagers
came to him and he offered to use on
them something that would make them
forget their traumatic past and this
monster is actually their hero Hiag
doesn't actually believe the Y and so he
kills him heading into the priest's
house he discovers this hidden entrance
of the other Temple within spotting Ito
covered in blood going to help her she
asks if the priest is already right just
as horrifying spiderweb started forming
around him and trapping him about to
defour his flesh she tells him they must
not disturb their King the one who gave
life to all the Y he's been feeding on
the village to gain power and is about
to wake up Hiag asks if they ate his
friend Maru just as he deploys some
explosives blinding Ito changing back
into a human KAG cautiously passes by
her to inspect the temple but she
surprises him disarming and badly
injuring him thinking quick he takes his
hand in her face actually pulls out her
entire mouth killing her for good
entering this mysterious place calls out
for the famous Demon King seeing webs
everywhere he spots this strange statue
covered in blood blowing it up that's
when he spots this pulsating Rock and
sees it bleed opening it up he sees Maru
inside dropping his knife in shock he
notices his best friend holding a human
head about to get him out Maru hisses at
him and sends him flying back causing
the entire area to crumble and explode
around Hiag freeing Maro and he leaves
injured Hiag behind a few hours later
Hiag barely escapes with his life badly
hurt and still in shock suddenly
remembering ya he runs to check on her
but spots her lifeless corpse heading
back to the Village he finds the rest of
the village has suffered the same fate
and he spots his ninja boss who's just
arrived to deliver some more urgent news
about his mission both Clan have found
out about their Leader's murder the boss
tells them there's no point in finding
Maro anymore and just come home but Hiag
refuses to abandon his best friend and
forcibly carries on his mission Alone 2
years later he continues his search for
his best friend but hasn't found any
leads for two years what an idiot
resting by this beach suddenly this
woman runs into him being chased by this
other ninja he watches them battling in
front of him blamed for a crime she
didn't commit she begs this ninja to
stop but he doesn't listen more ninjas
arrive also spotting Hiag and they
attack him forcing him to react he
swiftly subdues this one guy and while
the girl slices this guy's neck
desperate and outnumbered she
temporarily teams up with Hiag okay
right now we got bigger problems we need
to focus on taking on only one of our
enemies here and use the environment
behind us to our advantage girl dragged
us into this mess and now we have to
deal with it but at this point we're
screwed since we're outnumbered this is
why I would first escape this area by
pivoting sideways to limit the range of
this guy guys long-ranged weapons behind
one of the best ways to handle multiple
attackers is to basically keep moving
don't get surrounded by staying mobile I
would have worked on taking down the
biggest threat here besides the leader
and it would have been by handling this
lightweight guy with a long-range weapon
he's way faster than most of them and
more deadly since he can attack from a
distance in order to take him out while
minimizing any injuries I would lead him
to the force behind them and there would
be a lot of obstructions preventing him
from properly using that longrange
weapon forcing him to fight us up close
and give us the advantage and allowing
us to use our sword and deal with him
head on we're way more skilled than this
guy most likely once you take out the
faster guy we would have been able to
move onto the bigger guy and use the
cover of the forest to our advantage
what I'm saying is guys we need to use
gorilla Warfare fight dirty to take him
out the two fight for their lives barely
managing to take out the rest but they
do manage to injure this guy causing him
to blindly head into the ocean the girl
tries to stop him but hikkake stops her
warning that something is about to
happen and suddenly a giant explosion
occurs in the ocean just as this giant
horse arises charging straight for them
miraculously running over water it's a
Jesus horse interesting yag realizes
that this is an in ordinary creature and
easily tramples over the sky and he gets
ready for another battle but instead the
creature stops and asks him if he's the
one who killed his companions but Hiag
has no idea what he's talking about he
asks if it knows his friend marrow
getting ignored introduces himself as
maumi Niko ruler of the Seas warning him
there is someone else out there that
rules the land going over to lick these
corpses he tells him that when him and
the rule of the lands unite all of the y
in the world will be revived Hiag can
tell this thing knows Mara and a man to
spill the beans but maumi reveals that
Hiag already knows who Maru really is
pisses him off even more and he attacks
maumi but H that was a bad move the
creature easily knocks him back throws
him into the sea helplessly and he gets
ready to kill him okay yeah we're
definitely going to be screwed so I
guess the only thing we can do is to
stop this freaking overpowered Horse by
acting like Mike Tyson let me explain
Hiag made the criminal mistake of being
too near the water and is now deep
within enemy's territory literally
assuming we're not the chosen ninja and
just a regular old non anime protagonist
we need to be way more careful because
right now we can't beat this thing at
least not right now our best bet is to
treat this monster like a freaking
pescal shark getting back to Land is Our
Best Bet right now but swimming there is
going to take a lot of energy so right
now we need to brutally disable this
monster before we even try to leave
since we already have no weapons I would
simply go for this Monster's face and
eyes because there is a proven weak
point for sharks this would likely
produce the same result for this horse
creature since the nose is for horses
plays a much bigger part for them than
it does for humans it's much more
sensitive to the touch and that would
likely be the case here by blinding it
temporarily it would have allowed us to
head back to land before plotting her
next move because trying to fight a
water predator in water as a human is
about the craziest thing I've ever heard
of and I've watched a lot of anime and I
do it for living this is pretty crazy
thinking fast hiaki Dodges Maui's
underwater attack but quickly gets
countered getting dragged deeper and
deeper underwater forcing his eard drums
to burst in pain desperate he punches
mchu straight in the mouth killing him
allowing him to escape to the surface
deep underground another evil minion of
the ocean shiratsuyu updates his boss
Maru the Maui nomiko has died by someone
named Hiag their plans to revive the
ocean Yas will be delayed pissed off he
orders shiratsuyu to go down and hunt
Hiag so this doesn't happen again but uh
back on the beach Hiag finally returns
badly wounded and sees the ninjor from
earlier and thinking she's safe he tries
to leave but uh she follows him looking
for some shelter Hiag comes across his
Eerie Village cleaning himself off the
ninja woman introduces herself as ya the
same name as the last woman what the
freak this it creeping me out and heag
at the same time this is spooky wanting
to repay him she offers to ask this
Village if they can stay the night
approaching this one house she spots a
woman Inside holding a baby trying to
make a conversation a consents something
is a right and the woman asks her if she
wants to hold her baby and that's when
Hiag hears her scream running to save
her and spots her in shock looking at
this baby without a head more zombie
villagers start coming out but
harmlessly walk past them instead making
Hiag finally realize what's going on all
of these villagers all of them are
already dead they've just been walking
right in the middle of procession the
dead still attached to this world the
illusion of a peaceful Village
disappears letting them see what this
place really looks like human corpses
every reware but Hiag thinks this was
caused by a war if that's the case then
the village would have been burned
making him think the Yoma are behind
this indicating they're getting closer
to finding them and possibly Maro as
well updating ya on the mission as they
make cap the next morning ya wakes up
and finds Haka has left her oh no my
lover boy chasing after him she spots a
spirit appear right in front of her
telling her that she was slain by her
lover but she still wants him and is
looking for him in this area but ya
doesn't realize what kind of monster
this lover really is and that's when
these branches burst from the ground and
she gets caught in another y attack
nearby hikkake continues on his journey
but spots this monster in the tree
getting hit with some smoke he gets
knocked down not realizing that he's
just run to shiratsuyu attacking Hiag he
barely Dodges the strike stabs the
monster in the chest last minute and he
thinks woo it's over but suddenly the
ground beneath him bursts and it comes
out as this giant snake catching Hiag
off guard he gets grabbed by these
tentacles finding out that shiratsuyu is
still alive and now that he's about to
die he fires these darts and escapes
somehow this creature's grip thinking
it's over he spots ya and this Ghost
spirit held hostage rushing to save them
and he scales this tree and he deploys
tactical bombs at the tree monster while
the snake tries to reach him a nearly
dies hanging on for dear life he con
forced up this tree trapped on the last
branch and is about to die again Aya's
friendly Spirit from earlier transforms
into this cloud and charges at Hiag the
snake recognizes the girl Spirit as his
ex- lover and tells her to stay back
baby but she enters his body and causes
his body to burn and disappear Hell hath
no fury like a woman scorned after
hikkake gives AA [__] for putting him
through this side quest but she makes
him feel better by confessing feelings
for him and yeah yeah yeah yeah but
anywayss they're now getting closer to
finding the main Yan Nest suddenly they
run into a familiar face and Hiag knows
him a ninja named kazami he tries to
attack him declaring he's here to take
his life confusing hikkake while he
fights for his life kazami reveals that
their Lord made a deal with a Yoma to
borrow their power to help them become
the strongest clan in Japan it makes
Hiag realize that Maro is in fact the
evil demon king of the Yoma KMI says
they made a deal with Maro to gain Yoma
Powers but now they want them to kill
Hiag too with no choice Hiag strikes him
realizing his teammate is holding back
his power he reveals to him that he
can't be an outcast like Hiag and lives
to follow rules letting Hiag fatally
injure him he doesn't want to kill him
but tells him the Yoma are controlling
his entire Clan and are located nearby
in a place called nagashino Hiag is
forced to put his teammate out of his
misery and he says good bye to the ninja
clan that raised him now he goes full
Lone Ranger or Lone Wolf whatever you
prefer and he prepares to go head to
where KMI came from nagashino suiting up
he tells a to stay behind but she begs
him to let her come but he ignores her
like a stud and starts his journey
traveling he soon reaches nagashino but
starts to seeing hundreds of dead bodies
sensing Yoma near him he announces he's
come for marrow just then the ground
breaks under him forcing him to react in
self-defense rocks exploding near him
forcing him to gain some distance and
prepares for battle spotting Yas
surrounding him but that's when he runs
into Maro looking for answers he asks
his best friend why did he turn into
this evil King but Maro tells him that
he grew up tired of living life under
strict ninja rules and thinks there's
more to life than that and he tells Hiag
shocked face that the ninjas follow
their orders their entire lives it's a
stupid concept and they deserve to die
along with the rest of the world but he
wants to spare Hiag and make him join
his side considering it but that's when
he spots a in the distance and realizes
that she's followed him and is about to
die calling out for hik she snaps him
out of maro's evil traps making him
reject maro's offer and pisses him off
and he finally transforms in his true
evil form this monster Maro declares
that he will Feast on his blood and
suddenly a lightning strike occurs
nearby as the ruler of the sea maumi
returns and he's still alive it charges
Amaro heag realizes that if these two
unite the end of the world will happen a
tries to stop Maui but easily gets her
face crushed pissing Hiag off Maru and
Maui finally merge into this terrifying
monster revealing to hik that he is the
final sacrifice needed to revive the
Yuma Army not wasting any time they head
straight for hikage knocking him back
into this Rock beat the [__] out of him
all right I would try to kill Maro by
utilizing his greatest weakness our
neurochemical relationship for stoic
ninja Hiag hasn't been acting too ninja
likee and is way too emotional thinking
he could charge in as stop a Godlike
Warrior by just say hey I'm going to
beat him up that's dumb if I was Hiag I
would have played it smarter by trying
to figure out every Advantage we could
get for starters by not rushing in
instead would have camped out nearby to
watch maro's movement to pick up any
other Clues we could use and also we got
to recognize that Maro used to be our
best friend which is a huge deal that we
could have capitalized on because
connecting with someone on a close level
platonic or romantic it releases a
powerful cocktail of your body's
Feelgood hormones and this makes your
brain reward circuitry want you to do
this again and again and this doesn't
easily go away with someone this is why
I would try to leverage any potential
emotional vulnerabilities that Maro
might have for us this would include
making him reminisce about our old bro
days buying time when we try to close
the distance and make a hail merry last
attempt attack Adam at close range
because that's all that we got at this
point telling Hiag that the Y were
created from Humanity's hatred fear and
Prejudice and that they deserve what's
coming to them Maro pushes Hiag back
onto this cliff and he hangs for dear
life transforming into an even bigger
demon but hikkake proudly tells him that
he will live on his terms and when not
bow down to anyone pissing Maro off he
grabs Hiag a final time brutally slams
him against this rock at the little
energy left Hiag slices his eyes barely
evading his death and uses this moment
to slice maro's stomach critically
injuring him and forces him to go back
to his first form on the verge of death
and Delirious Maro calls out to hikage
as both of them collapse and the entire
air starts to crumble around them and
turns back into a peaceful Forest later
Hiag wakes up and realizes hey I'm saved
by my boo realizing her selfless act he
finally shows her some love with no home
to go back to two start traveling freely
but that's when they come across a dead
woman and her newborn son I goes to
rescue the baby while hiaki remembers
what Maru told him and wonders if he
made a mistake by staying human not
realizing that marrow deep in the
Underworld is about to be reborn but
what did you think about the video what
would you do different don't forget to
like subscribe and leave a comment down
below and as always don't forget to
check out our H toe playlist